[Music]
the twerp who won't arrest violent cons
says he's gonna handcuff Ron it's time
for
okay okay Mr tough guy
I don't know what the horse was there
for I would have assumed the horse would
have kicked him or something but you
know I guess I gotta it's too late now
California governor and walking oil
slick Gavin Newsom
doubling down against his warning to GOP
Presidential candidate Ron DeSantis for
sending migrants to California after all
just because Sacramento is a sanctuary
City in a sanctuary state that doesn't
mean a republican you know should act
like it
earlier this week Newsome tweeted to Ron
you small pathetic man this isn't
Martha's Vineyard kidnapping charges
well this tough guy acts is a real
stretch for Gavin he should just stick
to destroying California
plus her name is Gavin
there's no Gavin's here right
good
on top of that it's also tough to strike
fear when you look like you just escaped
from a J crew catalog
but I wonder is Ron just weakness
masquerading his strength
he's just weakness masquerading his
strength
yeah flailing
desperate for attention here's a
governor from the state of Florida
that is using taxpayer money and he had
to go to another state
to find people under false pretense I
don't think this I know this I talked to
the migrants
ah
he's about as threatening as a hamster
on NyQuil
Brian Kilmeade in a Jedi costume is more
intimidating
took forever to get that picture now
DeSantis is headed to California for a
fundraiser next week should he be
worried law enforcement officials are
going to arrest him when he walks off
the plane
should he be worried that law
enforcement officials in this state are
going to arrest him when he walks off
the plane and now we're getting into
hyperbole the bottom line is well just
work for it I mean I don't think it's
hyperbole you're the one raising the
issue of criminality potentially we
potentially
yeah
jackass
is the guy who brings up the arrest
potential for arrest the reporter goes
okay so you're gonna arrest somebody
let's not get into some hyperbole here
he's just taking you at your word
I guess our Democrats call Republicans
criminals for calling their Bluff they
don't mean it literally how could you be
so unsophisticated meanwhile on
Wednesday DeSantis defended sending
migrants to California
these Sanctuary jurisdictions are part
of the reason we have this problem
because they have endorsed and agitated
for these types of open border policies
they have bragged that they are
Sanctuary jurisdictions when they have
to deal with some of the fruits of that
they all of a sudden become very very
upset about that uh well what are these
people having to deal with um here I
don't see the sympathy for them can't
argue there and Newsome should be happy
to have new California residents they
lost over 200 000 residents between 2021
and 2022 and a lot of them moved to you
guessed it
Florida
no wonder Gavin's pissed he's being
dumped by someone new every single day
and they're all flocking to a younger
more successful dude
but don't worry about him I'm sure he'll
land on his hair
Charlie it is pretty funny imagine
boasting about your virtue and then when
somebody says prove it you say I'm
arresting you yeah exactly and I'm also
now just interested to hear about these
conversations that Gavin Newsom is
having with the migrants yes what are
they talking about exactly how to trim
his head exactly well this is yeah this
is exactly what Gavin Newsom asked for
he made California a sanctuary State Ron
DeSantis took the exact opposite stance
so I don't see what Newsome is whining
about the only good news I can say is
that when these migrants get to
California see how dumpy it is now
they'll probably just leave on their own
exactly and then they'll probably go to
Florida right probably Lee Lee
um what do you if you I keep always it's
prefacing everything if you were a
governor what would you have done when
these buses came
well New York shouldn't be a sanctuary
state New York City shouldn't be a
sanctuary City they had a new law that
was passed fortunately overturned by the
courts they were going to give
non-citizens the right to vote inside of
New York City and they're always looking
for new ways to make this state and city
even more of a sanctuary I want to ask
Gavin Newsom why is it that so many of
your residents are leaving for places
like Florida what what are you doing
they're making so many people leave why
is it that you have such a big budget
deficit but places like Florida have
such a big budget surplus I want Gavin
Newsom to answer that and another
hypocrisy test would be asking Gavin
Newsom what do you think about Eric
Adams in New York City sending all of
these migrants to all these red counties
if you're going to sit there on your
high horse tell us that you share the
same view that Eric Adams is wrong for
doing that I mean we have an issue and
you know this whole Red State versus
Blue State red City versus Blue City
what really needs to have happen is that
this governance Democratic Governors
calling the Democratic president and
saying We As Americans have this issue
and we need you to lead to secure our
Southern border and here's how but they
don't want to do it they want money and
they want they want power and Gavin
Newsom wants the attention more than
anybody he would love to be sitting in a
White House yeah he I think what he's
doing what he's doing is he's trying to
raise his own profile by going after
DeSantis and they use this analogy cat
that it's like when somebody goes on
Twitter right and somebody that starts
hammering at you hoping you'll respond
and you go like your brain's telling you
don't punch down but you do it anyway
you do that more than I do yeah I do
it's like not even close
it's true it's like it's like uh Gavin
is acting like a Twitter troll
yeah any
person would do that and because a
politician yeah of course what Rhonda
Sanders is doing is a stunt but that's
kind of what a lot of politics is he's
trying to call the bluff of certain
people and bring attention to this issue
and it's like hey buddy Gavin aren't you
trying to bring attention to yourself
also and it's so clear that's what he's
doing that he actually I think assumed
more people would realize that because
when he was asked arrest them he's like
don't be ridiculous yes exactly like no
I'm not being serious when I talk yes
I'm a politician this is politics so for
you to say okay that's a stunt to
somebody else when you just
plainly admitted that that was exactly
what you were doing that's got to be
embarrassing if you're the type of
person who could get embarrassed which I
don't think he is yeah but he didn't and
he had no he had no explanation for what
these conversations he had with migrants
they signed consent forms they were in a
party bus I never got you a party bus
you really not you've never got me
anything you know what he got me for you
know what he got me for Christmas one of
his Gutfeld branded Sharpies yes
it's worth a lot he got me two of them
he threw them at me from my office door
yes I did I did and I didn't even get a
thank you
I didn't even get a pen Greg yeah
Well we'd know what you do with it Tom
that's why we're so disgusting what are
you talking about he'd probably write
with it
I want him to keep it as like a
collectible but he would use it you know
what the funny thing is it's like Gavin
can't see what DeSantis is telling him
that this is a national problem and we
should be working together not doing
what you were saying the Red versus Blue
State but Gavin is like going I I am
Sanctuary but I'm not going to help I'm
not going to help you I mean it's
bizarre well talk about a cell phone too
In that clip he says uh oh you know he
didn't even have real uh uh illegal
immigrants down there he had to get them
from another place like this is how he's
bragging he's like in California we got
tons of illegals the borders wide open
we don't need to import our illegals
we're swimming in them
uh and also so he accuses uh DeSantis of
seeking attention and yet he's the one
who reacts every time DeSantis does
something he holds a press conference
yeah so he's going off of the heat
that's coming off of DeSantis I love
what DeSantis did and I love that it was
uh Martha's Vineyard I would go even
further than DeSantis I wouldn't just
land them at the airport on Martha's
Vineyard I would helicopter them and I
would have them parachute on to Obama's
property I think just I mean then Obama
would have to be nice to them right yeah
if if they were all there camping on his
property and you got to do it because I
I'm sure he has uh guards with guns you
know Guardians property you've got to
airlift them you gotta put do parachutes
right so you send them out in the
parachutes and they're all over Obama's
lawn and then he's got to come out and
give them cookies and milk and
everything like that I think it'd be
great I like this idea yeah I do too
you're probably going to get a call
after the show
they're a long detailed interview and
perhaps
trip hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else